[Music]
I'd walk down the hall and get called
[ __ ] by some folks a friend of mine
says you know Michael you weren't the
first homosexual PNG but you sure did
put a public face - in the eighties oh
[Music]
boy Cincinnati in the 80s it was kind of
a risky thing being known as scape Bell
aids have struck 1604 you had a life
span of six months maybe 18 months if
you were lucky there weren't effective
remedies then Procter & Gamble really
found this niche with paradox
prescription mouthwash being used by
people with AIDS
there was this disconnect P&G want to do
the science I want to do the marketing
but they didn't quite get because they
weren't gay that these are people's
lives things were not good for the LGBT
community in PNG the words sexual
orientation were not in the EEO policy
statement you know where are the gays
lesbians the words needed to be there
they were not ready to embrace that they
were not wanting to embrace it in no way
was Michael going to back away
I just kept at it
he was willing to put it on the line he
was willing to be an outlier it's either
gonna take you or you're gonna take it
and I have made up my mind
[Music]
policies do matter taking a stand
matters words matter it's important to
understand the struggle because the
truth is were always in the struggle
you